hello everyone I know that almost every
Sunday I say I have a game that will
improve your Sunday but it's not my
fault if that's true and this game I
believe will especially improve your
Sunday because this game is is so great
that I don't know I've actually seen
this this game for the first time so I
think maybe it will be for the first
time a lot of you are seeing this game
it's played between Vladimir Kramnik and
Peter Leko it's played in 2004 in their
World Chess Championship match we don't
have a photo of this event so here it is
it's not of the highest quality
unfortunately and it's not from this
game but it is from one of the photos in
this match you can find this game on
Chazz games.com I will put a link to it
in the description below if you you know
want to want to check it out some more
and before we continue with this game
congratulations in the previous video
most of you had it correctly it was
Samuel Reshevsky but for this video we
do have a more difficult for a challenge
as it is a Sunday so here it is best of
luck to all of you let's let's check it
out it was it some you all know him to
be a great chess legend today you know
him to be one of the greatest chess
commentators to commentate on live
events you know he battled great jazz
legends such as parliment Karpov and it
was taken in in the days when masters
was still popular but I actually think
the master is still very cool and that
the Masters will will have it come back
but you know what I will have to wait
and see so about this game it's it's
from their 2004 World Chess Championship
match and the game consisted of 14 games
and it's one of the very rare occasions
that the match ended in a draw so
Vladimir Kramnik retained his title in
that match but one game before the last
round it was actually Peter aleyko
who was in the lead and this tournament
but and kramnik needed a win in the
final game so it's one of the very rare
occasions in chess history that the
champion defending his title I was able
to win at the final game and retain his
title this is not the game I'm talking
about this
a different game this is game 8 from
their match and it features a move that
is so excellent that it's so great it
seems it appears to be invisible to to
even today's chess engines I've tested
I've tested this move with a lot of
different engines even stockfish 9 so
when we get to this point I will
definitely invite you to try out your
own engines and see if they they can
make a difference
but regardless let's check it out so II
for me five Knight to f3 Knight to c6
and Bishop to b5 the rule opens opening
and a six more fees defense we have
Bishop to a4 Knight to f6 crummy castles
Bishop to e7 rook to e1 we have b5
Bishop to b3 castles and c3 finally
kramnik invites aleko to play the
marshal attack as a chronic did avoid
the marshal attack in the previous games
in this championship here he invites it
with c3 and aleko of course goes for it
he plays d5 so the marshal attack is on
the board we have it captures Knight
captures Knight captures on e5 Knight
captures rook captures and c6 now some
other moves are possible here but the b7
is an idea you could go Knight to f6
move originally played in the kappa
blanka versus marshal but in this game
Michael goes for c6 we have d4 Bishop to
d6 now attacking the rook rook to e1 and
Queen to h4 the standard idea behind the
pawn sacrifice in in the marshal attack
going for that h2 pawn so g3 attacking
the Queen Queen to h3 rook to e4 and
here if you play the marshal attack I'm
sure you you've encountered rookie for
plenty of times and if you don't know
what to play here you could think okay
that's a very annoying move rook to h4
is coming my queen it's not really gonna
stay on h3 what do I do here well there
is a one move for black here the move is
actually G v g5 prevents rook to h4 it's
a move that were the first time this
move was played I was in 1947 in a game
between patrols and a new area
but wherever buck achieved a great
victory against Tigran Petrosian the
idea is of course you prevent rock h4
and of course if you capture then Queen
to a5 and this attacks your rook and the
bishop
you can only defend one of them after
you move or defend the rook simply Queen
captures Bishop will be enough to win
you the game but okay after g5 Queen to
f1 now Kramnik offers the trade of
Queens Queen to h5 we have nice - D -
Bishop to f5 attacking the rook and now
f3 this was all analyzed before the game
chromic had this on the board him and
his team analyzed this position
thoroughly before even considering
accepting lack of challenge - to a
marshal attack and now Knight to f6 was
played if you capture the look
immediately for example Bishop captures
then after F captures you attack the
knight Knight moves Queen f3 you either
you have to capture the Queen now as the
knight and III is under attack
so after Queen captures Knight captures
and out the knight and III is under
attack after we move it captures
captures and now simply Bishop captures
and g5 yes black is up the exchange but
white is up two points and White's pawn
structure is is awesome and black's pawn
structure is you know a rather sad so
this would be an excellent position for
white and white is up two points so
instead after f3 not capturing rook but
Knight to f6 attacking the rook now with
the night and now the knight will not be
under attack after the rook is captured
so rook back to e 1 we have rook 88 and
now rook captures rook captures and now
a for the general idea of the marshal
attack has definitely been been achieved
here black manage the trade off one rook
the other rook is now active all of the
pieces black have has are active and
white still has to figure out how to
develop the bishop and the rook
if white manages to do this then of
course white will be better we have a
four Queen to g6 now and now a capture
some beef are a capture some b5 this
Queen to g6 move is something Peter
really had considered and really had to
you know see far into the future
because what what he has in store for
chronic is not for the faint of heart
so a capture some beef I was played and
now Bishop to d3 okay attacking the
Queen and also the pawn on b5 we have
Queen to f2 and now definitely capturing
the pawn we are a character son b5 would
be would be an idea but Lego goes for
for something different
he goes for rook to e2 and now what do
you do here
well after aleko played rook to e2
chronic media sleep late Queen captures
on e2 and it seems like a seems like a
winning move and in fact chronic had
this position on the board before the
game he he and his team decided that
this was of course winning for white
it's okay but shop capture Sonny to was
played and now B captures on a6 it seems
that for for the Queen the only
compensation like who has chronic has is
this rook a rook and a nice pass pawn
that is ready to go to a7 and a8 so you
kind of don't want to allow 0.287 in
point to a eight and this is the
position I've been talking about so here
of course Bishop captures on a6 is the
idea and every engine I've tried gives
Bishop captures on a6 but this is why
this game is so famous and this is why
this move by Peter like Oh is so famous
it's one of the legendary moves played
in chess history and you know I really
do want you to pause the video here and
try to find this move give it a minute
or two or how you know if you can afford
more give it more but even if you don't
find it or you don't really know what to
find then I also invite you to try out
your engines maybe your engine can help
you here because I haven't found an
engine that can actually solve this
position so I will give it a couple of
seconds like I said for those of you who
found it congratulations you are a true
a true
you know achiever of legendary moves
played in in chess history and for those
of you who want to enjoy the show
because I believe this
one of those positions where most of us
will just enjoy the show this movies be
beyond you know the visibility of
engines here aleko played queen 2 d 3
and once once you play this move
actually all of the engines will tell
you that black is black is completely
winning here because now the idea of a 7
doesn't work
Queen B 3 stops a 7 with the next idea
after you play a 7 then comes Queen to
e3 check
kingi - and now Bishop captures on f3
this comes with check now you have to
capture the bishop if you go H 3 g4 is
coming and you're getting checkmated if
you go to f1 then we need to check and
again you're getting checkmated so
Knight captures on f3
now comes Queen e2 check King g1 Knight
to g4 and this is the move so there's
really not a lot you can do here Queen
to f2 check is coming King has the move
Queen f1 check is coming so now if you
play a queen check ok now you have a
queen again a king has to move and after
Queen captures and c6 because there
really is no good move here for white
after white makes any move Queen f2
check is coming King moves and now Queen
to f1 check and Knight has to block and
now Knight to F 2 will be checkmate
so only one of the one of the reasons
why a 7 doesn't work in this line so ok
chronic plays King to f2 it's the
strongest move recommended by the engine
so chronic finds over the board that
this in fact doesn't work and that's the
entire preparation he he and his team
made prior to this game simply it
doesn't work against alekos brilliant
Queen to d3 move so Bishop captures on
f3 once again like oh please the only
move that allows him to continue playing
this game for advantage Knight captures
on f3 and now Knight to e4 this comes
with the check and this is the move like
again had to see when he played Queen to
d3 move because without this this is the
only continuation that works for black
after Queen to d3 so every move will
echo played after Queen to d3 is the
only good move
or black so kinky one by Kramnik here if
you try some other ideas for example
kingi - then you're getting checkmated
Queenie - check tink has to move Queen
captures on f3 and there is really
nothing you can do here whatever you do
even if you try to give up a piece by
Bishop to e3 black will simply ignore
you bushel captures and either you will
wait for a discovery order you will
capture and get checkmate it on the
other hand after Knight to e4 check you
could go King to g1 this also doesn't
work simply Queen captures on f3
immediately now Queen f2 check is coming
and after you prevent this you have to
move the bishop so the rook will cover
the first rank but then simply Queen
captures King G - Queen f2 check King
gage 3 h5 is coming with g4 doesn't
matter what a wife plays Rock - h1 now
g4 check King moves Queen f6 check King
moves and Queen g5 will be checkmate
so after this Knight to e4 check King to
e1 was played and now again aleko plays
the only move that gives black the
winning position Knight captures on c3
of course the threat is Queen - E -
checkmate so you do have to capture the
knight be captures on c3 was played and
now Queen captures on c3 this comes with
check we have King to have two and now
Queen captures on a1 so now the past
pawn isn't really isn't really all that
great and now it's you know it really
does seem like the bishop and tonight is
a little compensation for the Queen a 7
was played but now comes h6 there is no
way to promote to this pawn now we have
h4 and g4 and after this g4 move was
made while micronic resigned the game
and he said after the game that it is a
beautiful beautiful game that will be
remembered in the history of chess and
indeed this game was remembered in the
history of chess and especially alekos
amazing Queen to d3
he resign because there is no more
contra player in what every play black
will simply pick up the a pawn and then
you have no compensation to even
consider playing this position
so yeah this is a once again the
position after this beat captures on a6
laço found this beautiful Queen to d3
move and I'm really interested can how
many of you were able to find this move
and you know if any of you tried putting
this position into an engine was your
engine able to find Queen d3 in this
position because is the only move
available to black now that that's good
for black and it's interesting once you
play it then the engine says like oh yes
of course black is black is completely
winning but without playing it the
engine doesn't see it so very
interesting so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I really do hope it
improves your Sunday and of course you
know I hope your Sunday was excellent
even before watching this game but now
that it's even better I would like to
thank a William Fusco buses Carlton Yura
and autumn lever for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here I think all for
watching and I will see you soon are
probably starting tomorrow which the vs.
Coulson match and we'll see how many of
the games I will cover from the Louvin
tournament and although this is only one
game from the aleko versus Kramnik match
I think I will also show a game 1 and
game 14 when I get the chance so yeah
once again thank you and I will see you
soon